hey guys this is dennis the founder
think era and i'm david griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of kick-ass 2
directed by jeff wadlow not matthew
vaughn this time produced by producer
right the director um yeah I had heard a
lot of like bad things about this movie
but I actually liked it i thought i
thought it's not as good as the first
one but i thought it was a worthy sequel
to the to the kickass movie and I felt
like it kind of had the same tone and
feel to it and i don't think the action
was as good but it was still
entertaining yeah it was i think this
was a series is entertained at the comic
book series is the same way it's
entertaining it's never been i don't
know much more for that for me but it
was good that this was solid I think was
just trying to be more of a personal
story I think there's a little bit more
action in the comic book I mean it's
good it's just I think like I felt
sometimes some of the emotional stuff
didn't didn't hit but you could tell
they're trying to be dramatic in some of
these areas like when they have the
conversation like it's about being here
I was like okay like you know this is
good but I mean it was still good i like
the cast you know Khloe's awesome yeah
trailers hit girl and I really did like
the castle is a good i think the stand
out guy was probably fire on Dana faiz I
it was great there's a lot of there's a
lot there was a lot of standouts around
me I mean I I love jim carrey is Colonel
stars and stripes Cena I thought his
character was hilarious just funny cuz
he was like talking against the movie
and I'm like I was like one of your
better performances in a while you guys
did a good job in that role exactly and
you know uh Mother Russia yeah she's
cool yeah yeah like and I mean hey girls
always awesome it is a little weird see
Cena Chloe Moretz just because she's
like so much older and taller now you
know in in the first kick ass it was you
know she's you know she's tiny and she
was like kicking ass and so's
interesting this time like I mean still
cool seeing her kick ass but it's not
he's not the same no no going up yeah so
and also the kind of like almost had
like the side story of her like trying
to give up being a superhero or have you
know a crime fighter
uh but then this this whole kind of like
Mean Girls thing came into it right yeah
which I actually liked it I thought it
was cool i mean they kind of resolved it
a little too quickly but i think that
was just cuz you know that they didn't
want to me linger with it too much but
they kind of resolve that that whole
story line a little bit fast i think
they did a good job actually enjoyed
kick ass to the movie morta to kick ass
to the comic book that mark miller road
but sometimes I think he does some
extremely violent things there's been
violence the comic book towards women
there's a scenic and probably if you see
the movie can tell like they kind of
went around it and didn't go all the way
which is the conflict they do I think
sometimes just there for shock value and
I like that they kind of had more jokes
in this one and tried to kind of stay
away from the show I thought was
actually but was gonna be more violent
when Jim Carrey was talking about it was
it was violent buisness vials and I
thought it was going to be and I thought
that they did a better job in the movie
kind of balancing the violence and the
seriousness did a better job I think
this is better than a comic book kind of
like the first month I did a great job
too okay yeah and you know I thought
mclovin you know yes / mince pies I
thought he was great to as the
[ __ ] like Oh John liga zon was
like I'm not calling you that you know
that kind of says it's good yeah yes I
mean Faison yes good i like I liked him
and kick asses chemistry I just teaming
up I love the whole justice for
everything yeah yep mmm have they're all
joining together and likes this guys are
like just like almost like it's like a
neighborhood watch you know like they're
not really crime fighters at all and
then just having a Clark Duke yeah as
part of the team i was was was pretty
funny it was nice balance I'm he had
some people like it like a mom and you
know dad who lost her kid yeah I'd like
a nice balance of Jesse's p I mean it is
trying to be more realistic like what
would superhero life and be like even
though this movie's crazy but still like
what super here would be life if they
were real people being superheroes and
they kept kind of enforcing you know
that point throughout the movie but yeah
I thought it was good i mean it's always
entertaining it's great cast great
characters I guess I'm just never like
I'm not blown away by the movie I think
it's good i think it deserves its like
in the 20s on run to me yeah it's nice
it's i think it is every better reviews
than that i deserve better view but then
the people that I've talked to my circle
of most people have said the same thing
where they liked it but it wasn't as
good as the first one yeah it was just
kind of where I'm falling right now I
remember just I was watching I was
laughing and having a good time you know
the hell of the theater and I was like
okay I'm glad I saw that was good
probably see it again but it wasn't
anything like I had like go tell
somebody no I gas too and it was so good
yeah no no like we're kick-ass one I was
like no you gotta see right you gotta
see this but like a kick-ass 2 it's like
oh if you like the first one I think
you'll like the second one I think you
know people are being a bit harsh on it
yeah I think so i'm not sure why i don't
really know why I mean maybe people just
against the violence or ya know maybe
it's the Jim Carrey controversy right
type of stuff yeah it's like I think and
maybe this is its might be going on a
deeper subject I don't go too far off
subject here but it's like I think this
movie maybe I think now with all the
violence on TV and game of thrones you
see it in walking to I think there has
to be like an emotional weight tattoo it
and I think tacacs is kind of
light-hearted I mean it over some
emotional women it's still light hearted
maybe critics are being turned off we're
like hey this just violence for the sake
of violence which I've had issues with
in the comic book but that's just kind
of how it is it's just kind of fun it's
not trying to say something about
society I don't think it's not trying to
do well I mean there are like I think
little darker parts in this one compared
to the first one um you know mixed with
the humor right well but I don't know I
just thought it was pretty pretty fast
yeah the movie is a bit long I felt but
then I kind of felt that about the first
movie anyways so that's like one of the
negative parts of it and you know there
is I think maybe a pacing not pacing
issue but just like because they kind of
jump between kind of a Hit Girl
storyline and the kick-ass storyline so
it's a little less focused you know yeah
but i don't know but i still liked it it
was good yeah i was going to tell
everybody out there kick-ass 3 mark mark
millar's a new comic book is out now I
think we've the first issues out so
definitely go check that out to see
where the story is going the movie don't
spoil anything it does end a little bit
differently than in kick-ass 2 the book
then he's a little different but it's
still yeah it's still good so solid
gotta stick around for the cigarette for
the credits yeah there's a credit
there's a frat see it's short but yeah
it's always work check out yeah
definitely so yeah what would you get a
give a kick-ass 2 i'd give it a b-minus
I don't mean that in a bad I think it
was good it's just nothing really stood
out I think that brought it over the top
for me but it was still good still worth
seeing I'll see it again buddy I
definitely give it to be minus okay I'm
gonna give it kind of like a be almost
be plushies yeah I think I enjoyed it
more than you did I just yeah I just you
know was expecting garbage and I came
away you know having a good time you
know and and felt kind of like a
continuation of the first one so I'd say
you know no you don't have to rush out
and see it but if you did like the first
one I think you know I think it's worth
seeing and then if you don't see in the
theaters definitely watch it on like
blu-ray yeah check it out yeah we're
alright guys so that's what we thought
you can post your comments below on the
website fing caricom check us out on
youtube at our youtube page think you're
a pro and make sure you subscribe to
that channel and also we're on twitter
minds at think kara i'm at griffin de
and we also a facebook page that's a
facebook com / think carroll fans
you